the Scouse Reverb. Welcome back. Hey,
what's up, man? What's up, man? You see
what I got to do with you? It's been a
bit difficult tonight. I'm not going to
lie. There's been um that Tik Tok brings
out some some characters, I'll say the
least. Yes, it does. Yes, it does. All
right, man. I'm going to run the
argument with you. You ready? Yeah.
Yeah, of course. Um before we get
started, can I just say um you'll have
to let me know when you're doing your
next um live where I can come back and
um take on your challenge again about um
proving Jesus was a Muslim. I'd like to
do that one again. Okay. But we'll see.
I'll be live again Wednesday. I'll be
definitely be able to join. I came back
on the last not the last one. Sorry, the
one before, but you was a bit
overwhelmed. I remember. Okay. You ready
now? Yeah. No. All right. Do you believe
that Islam is reliable? I do. Yeah.
Awesome. Would you trust a religion that
has corrupted scripture? It's a bit of a
bit of a shaky question. I mean, you
say, would I believe a religion that has
a corrupted scripture? But are you
asking me would I believe the religion
or would I believe the scripture? The
religion itself is the religion. Would
the religion be reliable, trustworthy if
it contained corrupted scripture? I
wouldn't believe in that scripture. No.
Would you believe in the religion? No.
No. I mean, for for simplicity of
answer, I'll say no. All right. The
Torah, was that an Islamic scripture
revealed? Um, it was revealed to Moses.
Was it corrupted? The Well, I mean, if
you want to call it that. Yeah. What
about the Gospel of Jesus? Was that an
Islamic scripture? See, when you're
saying was it an Islamic scripture?
Islamically, it was revealed as a
scripture to Moses and to Jesus, peace
be upon. Right. So, it's a scripture
that belongs to the religion of Islam,
right? Well, it belonged to to them and
their people at that time, you know.
Yeah. G Jesus was an Islamic prophet,
right? Yeah. Yeah. I would say that.
Okay. And he received an Islamic message
called the NGO, the gospel, right? Yeah.
And eventually this Islamic message, the
gospel got corrupted, right? Yeah. All
right. Same thing with the Psalms.
Psalms is is in Islamic scripture,
right? Where does it say that in the
Quran? Say it again. I said, where does
it say that in the Quran? The Psalms.
Yeah. Yeah. It says that we gave David
the Psalms. The Zabore. Think off the
top of your head. What? What? What
chapter versus? I'm having a brain fart.
Come on. You're the sh you you know what
off the top of you that more better than
I do.
What's that? Hold on. Let me I'll pull
it up. We gave David the Psalms Quran
verse.
1755.
1755. That's right. Chapter 17 verse 55.
And to David we gave the
Psalms. Say that again. I'll say that.
Say that. Say that one more time. Oh
yeah. Sorry. Um Yeah. Yeah. So um where
it says we gave David the book. Well it
says Zabore in the Arabic which means
psalms. Yeah. I mean it's from my
understanding zabore can it doesn't
directly translate to psalms. Can mean
writings I think it is. I mean my
Arabic's a little bit. No worries. So,
but either way, either way, if the Quran
says whatever was revealed to David, I I
would believe that that is correct yet.
All right. And that got corrupted. I
mean, I haven't I haven't looked into
the Psalms. I mean, I've read the
Psalms, but I haven't looked into the
actual corruption of it too much. So, um
Okay. But I mean, we we could go along
with that for now if you like that it is
corrupted. We could go along with that.
I mean, as I said, I don't want to I
don't want to like claim that. So, I
would I if I were you, I'd stick with
the safe side and say that it's it's
intact. It's preserved. Not that I
wouldn't default to it being corrupted.
That's a dangerous position to default
to. No, I'm just I'm just trying to be
nice on seeing as we're having a
convers. So, as I said, I wouldn't I
wouldn't like to make a claim either
way, but for the purpose of the
conversation, I can I can go along with
that. All right. Well, okay. So, at
least two. Let's let's disregard the
Psalms. The Torah and the Gospel. Yes,
these Islamic scriptures within Islam
got corrupted. And so at least Quran
Islam has at least two corrupted
scriptures. And so therefore it's
untrustworthy because remember you
wouldn't believe in a religion. You
wouldn't trust a religion that has
corrupted scriptures in it. Yeah. But
the the thing is is that first and
foremost I believe in the Quran. Yeah.
Yeah. That's one out of the four. Can I
just move on this point? Can I ask why
you were hesitating on saying the number
three before? What was that about?
Hesitating for what? You know, you you
said the number three a few times and
then you said I shouldn't have said the
number. What was that about? Oh, cuz
Allah says do not say three.
Oh man, you nothing is your
Yeah. He says don't say three, man. And
I I slipped up in this live a few times.
You cracked me up once. Oh yeah. Sorry.
It was just I I was a little bit I
didn't understand what you didn't get
it. You didn't get it. Yeah. Sorry. So,
moving on. Um, yeah, I believe in the
Quran. Yeah. And the Quran tells me to
believe in the Torah and that was
revealed to Jesus, peace be upon them.
Yeah. Now, it there's a few things
there. First and foremost, um, can I
just ask you before I move on? Um, like
you know when it says the Torah and
Injil, do you believe that the Torah is
the revelation that was when it's
mentioned in the Torah and Injeal? Do
you believe that the Torah is the
revelation that was given to Moses and
the angel was the revelation that was
given to Jesus? That's what it says.
Yeah. No, but I'm saying is that what do
you believe that's what it's referring
to? Yeah, that's what that's what it
what else could it be referring to?
That's what it says. No, no, I'm just
I'm just clarifying your position. Yeah.
See? So yeah, the the angil and the
Torah that you know Moses and Jesus
revealed to the people went around
preaching and that the followers carried
on throughout the generations and the
Torah being the first five books of the
Old Testament and the NGL being the
gospels the four gospels in the New
Testament. Yep. Yeah. So in that regards
it's not necessarily referring to the
rest of the Old Testament and the rest
of the New Testament. Would you agree?
Not necessarily because the Quran does
say that it's confirming what is with
them and so what is with them they have
it all. No, I know I'll get on to that
but but just for the sake of the Torah
was what was revealed to Moses which is
believed to be the first five books of
the Old Testament and the Gospel of
Jesus peace be upon him is the believed
to be the four gospels in the New
Testament. So for instance, the letters
of Paul and then the writings on Joshua
and the rest of the Old Testament isn't
necessarily what was given to Moses or
Jesus, was it? Not necessarily.
Um, but I think that there could be a
case made that when gospel is used, it's
referring to the entire New Testament or
Torah is referring to the old the entire
Old Testament. There's there's a case
that could be made there. But a simpler
a simpler position is yeah the first
five books and the four accounts of the
gospel. So when it's talking about that
if we're if we're taking that then we
can't necessarily attribute it to the
rest of those other writings. Let's say
that we only attribute it to the four
accounts of the gospel and the first
five books of the Old Testament. Let's
say that we attribute Torah to that and
gospel to that and Jill to that. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. So Torian and Gio were
corrupted. Yeah. No, it's just because
in some of the conversations that that
you've had, and I don't want to bring a
straw man and say that other Christians
have had that I've seen them having, but
when they refer to some of these verses
from the Quran that mention it
confirming previous scriptures, they
instantly attribute it to the whole
Bible. Like I said, there there's a case
that could be made, but that's that's
neither here nor there right now. Okay.
Okay. We'll move on. So I know that you
said that you have the Quran and you
believe in the Quran. Yeah. But the
Quran is part of this religion that has
corrupted scriptures in it. So the
religion of Islam itself is
untrustworthy. Well, no, not necessarily
because in the verses referred to the
previous scriptures, you're stretching
Avery. You look like you're getting fed
up with me already. I I' I've been here
for almost three hours, man. Okay. Okay.
I'll I'll forgive it. So not that it's
my place to forgive, but I understand.
No, it's okay. for your grace. I
appreciate it. Oh, don't hit me with
that one. I I appreciate you taking the
time that you do, especially with some
of the trolls that you've had. It's um I
can understand it could be tedious. Um
as you know, I genuinely do come here
with a level of sincerity to just kind
of you know, I know you, man. You don't
got to you got to say that. It's okay. I
know you like the others. I appreciate.
So, yeah. So in terms of when the Quran
is talking about previous scriptures um
so for instance in surah ala which is um
I think chapter 5 yeah I think mentions
it in 47 and 48 and a couple of other
places in that chapter um but it says
that we've revealed to you the book and
truth which is the Quran. Do you you
would leave I I think you had this
conversation with someone the other day
and there was actually a Muslim saying
that he didn't think that that meant the
Quran which was stressing me out but oh
it had to be the Quran. Yeah. So Allah
has revealed the book to us. Um so the
book in truth is the Quran. Yeah. And it
confirms that which came before it
scripture. Yep. But then it also says um
that it is a criterion over or it
doesn't say that. It says not. Yeah,
Muhamm. I appreciate the correction, but
Mahiman itself um is a word that I mean
it translates to a few different things.
Um it can be like guardian or witness or
overseer or protector. Would you agree
with some of those definitions? Yep. So
with it being a witness, it's speaking
to the Quran as a scripture that attests
to the truth or falsehood of the
previous. No, not it doesn't. You can't
attest to falsehood. Attesting to
something is like you're, you know,
validating something, you know. Well, if
if you attest to the truth, then you it
attests it attests that the scriptures
are true. Yeah. But it attests to if it
attests to the truth within the
scripture, then that separates it from
the falsehood. Does that make sense? I
hear what you're saying. The Quran
doesn't say that. The Quran doesn't say
that there's some falsehood in the
scripture that it separates the truth
from. No, it says it's a Mahiman over
there. Yeah. Yeah. So that doesn't mean
that it it it's a judge over it. It's
not a judge over it. It's a witness to
it. It's a protector of it. It doesn't
decide what's true or false in the
scripture. Yeah. But if we've been in
the course of the Lord and we called the
witness to the stand, the witness would
attest to the truth within whatever
testimony is being given or not. So the
the witness is supposed to confirm what
is being said, right? Well, the witness
will confirm the truth of what's being
said, not totality. A witness has a
witness gives a testimony that either
cooperates with a story already laid out
or doesn't cooperate. Right? So, this is
saying that it is a witness to it. So,
it's not a witness against it, it's a
witness to it. So, it's in line with the
scriptures. It's a witness over it. Does
that make sense? It's a witness over it,
not to it. Okay. Um, let me grant you
your position. Your Quran has corrupted
or your is your religion has corrupted
scripture. Can I get to say thank you
your grace? Yeah. Your your religion has
corrupted scripture. You said that you
can't trust a religion that has
corrupted scripture. Yet so far we know
that Islam has at least two corrupted
texts, Torah and the Gospel. So with
that being said, the Quran or Islam is
not reliable. No, because this this is
the difference in our position is that
for me as a as a Muslim, I have to
believe in the Torah that being revealed
to Moses and um the angel being revealed
to Jesus, peace be upon them both and
they got corrupted. So I No, but I first
and foremost I have to believe that that
those scriptures were revealed to those
prophets. That's nice. And they got
corrupted, right? Yeah. So you can't
trust this religion because its texts
have gotten corrupted. So where it says
um to believe in the book, Yeah. believe
in the Quran. So if we believe in the
Quran, then we can believe in what the
Quran says. Yeah. Would you agree with
me? I feel like you're missing my point.
Sorry. What do you think my point is?
Your point is that if there is scripture
that is being revealed that has been
corrupted. Yeah. and I have claimed that
I wouldn't believe in corrupted
scripture or I wouldn't believe in a
religion that has corrupted scripture
then clearly that shows that my position
is false because I believe in the Quran
which you believe has or I believe in
Islam which you believe has corrupted
scripture. Do I believe that or do you?
I don't believe that my I don't believe
that Islam has corrupted scripture.
Okay. So let me ask it again. The Torah
is it corrupted? Yes. Is the Torah in
Islamic scripture? Yes. So, Islam has
corrupted scripture. But I love the way
you got God logic written above your
head. Yeah. And I love the way you're
applying the logic. Yeah. But it doesn't
necessarily stand up in the sense of you
you're reading the scripture in a way
that then leans towards your bias. And I
know that you could just turn around.
Hold on. What scripture did I quote in
in reference to what? What scripture did
I quote? I don't know. You've mentioned
the sword of the angel on the Quran. So,
what scripture did I quote in in our
conversation on this topic? What
scripture did I quote? I'm going to go
with the Quran. I didn't I didn't quote
anything. Oh, okay. Sorry. Are you
listening? You paying attention, man?
I'm trying to. So, what's your point in
that? I didn't quote any scripture. The
only thing that I quoted were your
words. Okay. I asked you a question. You
gave an answer. But it's based it's
based on the premise of your question.
Is that you know what I mean? Based on
the premise of your answer.
My my answer did not precede your
question. And yeah, but you the
conclusion is based on your answers, the
premises and your answers. Your an your
answer is step one Islam is reliable.
Step two, you would not believe in a
religion that has corrupted texts.
Step three, Islam has corrupted texts.
Where is that? Because you're saying
because because I'm stating that the
Torah and the NGL is being corrupted
that that means that Islam is not
corrupted. Let's do it. Let's do it one
more time. One more time. No, but sorry.
Can I just clarify me point? What you It
sounds like you don't get it. I I I do
get it. I get the premise of your
question and I understand the the line
of questioning that you got. Okay. Where
what where are we miss? Where's the
disconnect? Because you said like when
we got to step three, you're like where
is that? Like like that wasn't
established. So where what about step
three? Islam has corrupted texts. Where
do where is that? What where's the
disconnect there? Because Islam has the
Quran. Yeah. What else does it have?
Well, it doesn't have the complete
Torah. It doesn't have the complete
inje. So it has corrupted Torah and a
corrupted inje. My belief is that. Yeah.
But in terms of so Islam has corrupted
texts, right? No. Judaism's got
corrupted text. Christianity's got
corrupted text. Islam has Is is the
Torah a Jew a text of Judaism or is it a
text of Islam? The Torah was the was the
the the revelation that was given to
Moses for the Again, my question was
very simple. You know me, you've been
watching a long time. So please do not
revert into what they are. I ask him not
to. Good. I ask straightforward
questions. All I need is straightforward
answers to what I asked. Yeah. Is the
Torah a text of Judaism or is it a text
of Islam? Okay. For the purpose of being
able to continue with our conversation,
Avery, I will agree. It is a scripture
of Islam. It is a scripture of
monotheism. Good. So, the Torah is a
text of Islam. Same question for the
Gospel. Is the gospel a text of
Christianity or is it a text of Islam?
The the inil is the revelation given to
Jesus which is a a scripture of Islamic
monotheism. Awesome. So the Torah and
the Injil the gospel are scriptures of
Islam. Were these scriptures of Islam
corrupted? Yeah. So Islam has corrupted
scriptures, right? And uncorrupted
scriptures or incorrupted scriptures. So
it has it has two corrupted scriptures,
one unknown. The song I'm allowed to say
today. And then the Quran uncorrupted.
So we have two corrupted scriptures, one
unknown. We don't know yet. The Quran
uncorrupted. So two out of the four are
corrupted scriptures within Islam.
Right. Well, I would I really don't want
to watch me head. I don't believe
they're within Islam because I believe
that the truth that is within those
scriptures, the Quran has the Quran
attests to the truth that is within
those scriptures because as I said to
you in one of our one of our previous
conversations, I believe in some of the
things that are in the Bible and the
Torah. You know what I mean? Because
there are things that line up with what
the Quran states. All right, that's it
for me. Thanks for coming, bro. Avery, I
hope this doesn't impact us having
future conversations. It might. I hope
not. And can I just ask before I go and
and and I'll leave politely without you
having to throw me out the window. So,
can we just clarify that from now on,
even if you are referring to the Torah
and Inil as being affirmed by the Quran
as previous scriptures. We're not
talking about the totality of the Bible.
We're just talking about the revelation
given to depends on the argument that's
being made. Like I told you, it sounds
like that you didn't understand this
either when I said this, and I'm I'm
starting to get this from you that uh
either either you play with me and you
play dumb. Either you play dumb, you
play like you don't listen, or you truly
don't listen. So before before I, you
know, I'm going to just let you go right
now. Okay. Stay.